i just had a vision that one day dolly
parton comes on and you come on and
guest host that episode
because i'm going to be getting a studio
in nashville starting on september 1st
really
if you do that can you let me know i'm
letting you know oh if she's gonna do it
yes yeah that's gonna be a goal i'm
gonna set
or if you're doing it and i can come and
walk dude that doesn't matter it doesn't
matter and i see her doing this
i really do let's put it out to the
universe now make this happen are you
moving in asheville
um i'm getting a place there okay so i'm
gonna be
there a lot but i'm also we're not we're
keeping this
and we're keeping you know everything
keeping my place here and stuff
so i'm just kind of testing it out yeah
but yeah maybe that'd be fun maybe we'll
come maybe we do some a couple of
episodes morgan wallin's going to come
on one
which i'm so excited about even though i
didn't ask him yet
he'll do it but i think he will do it
yeah
um that is awesome yeah i'm just kind of
excited just to be able to like i think
just have different types of people yeah
but i would but it's so funny because i
was
listening to dolly parton sings that i
will always love you mm-hmm a lot of
people don't know she did that oh yeah
people think it's whitney houston she
did was great but no she
you know what she wrote that she wrote
that after she she quit that show that
she was on
no way really oh it's a haul for porter
wagner she wrote it for porter wagner
who is her boss
she was on that show with him and she
quit and he got pissed
because um she she made the show
wayne porter she's what's that song
somebody's
i don't know were you wayne woman enough
to take my man
no it's like you ain't so and so and you
ain't porter i think it was her
oh yeah yeah i know what you're talking
about yeah yeah that's a newer song
oh it is i think so wayne johnny or
something like that yeah
yeah that's a newer song i don't know
who sings that um
um oh yeah oh you ain't dolly and you
ain't poor ashley monroe
yeah yeah i was listening to her the
other day man i like her me too
her voice her voice is different than
anything else i've ever heard she's got
like a
yeah almost like a dolly voice i could
see that like dolly's voice is like you
know dolly's singing odd
it's like father time just damn busting
in your ear
you know she's singing it feels good i
just love her
but i will always love you put this on a
little bit nick we'll listen to a few
seconds and then we'll get out of here
thank you but we're not ready we got a
man is there a more beautiful woman
she did it it's still beautiful yeah my
[Music]
god
you could give me a reach around he
wouldn't get jealous
this is a bucket list i never knew i had
this
yeah yes
[Music]
yeah you know what i'm pretty confident
wish i looked like 1970s oh i think you
got a lot of dolly
thank you good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah